Dans « Pourquoi On Dit ? »,
je vous raconte ce qu'il se cache
derrière les expressions de la langue française.
Alors abonnez-vous
et n'oubliez pas...
que je suis cloche !
Voilà !
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Pourquoi disons-nous que nous « bullons »
ou que nous « coinçons la bulle » ?
quand nous ne faisons rien.
Ce sont les militaires qui sont à l'origine
decette expression.
Au milieu du XXème siècle,
la précision d'un tir d'artillerie
nécessitait quela plateforme de l'engin
soit à l'horizontale.
A l'époque,
pas de gps ni de laser.
Les militairesutilisaient
un niveau à bulle.
Ils l'ajustaient
jusqu'à ce que la bulle soit coincée
entre les deuxpetits traits.
Une fois l'opération réussie,
ils attendaient les ordres.
Et pendant ce temps,
ilsne faisaient rien
si ce n'est
jeter un oeil sur la bulle
pour vérifier qu'elle était bien coincée.
D'où l'expression,
« buller »
ou « coincer la bulle ».